hennion alors maintenant on va passer à
la fin du monde donc et à chaque sortie
si on arrive c'est la fin du monde donc
accrochez vos ceintures c'est le 11 août
1999 et on va en parler avec elizabeth
teissier et paco rabanne
m
bonsoir bonsoir parcours mais
sérieusement il furieux pourquoi
serrières 10 ans parce que je me lève
violemment diot 2 mai 1 m 78 pensent
être à appellation la fin du monde la
fin du monde c'est dans cinq milliards
d'années assure luu travail quand le
sait va devenir une géante rouge
champagne au programme est là messieurs
mélange août le 11 août dans 5 milliard
d'années la possibilité de destruction
de paris cette année là les parts émises
dans toutes les prophéties sait que
paris par an mais on est content
bon d'accord excusez-moi pas qu'au
premier la première boule à une question
avant de commencer pourquoi vous êtes
toujours habillés en noir seront pas
fait dans la vie passée j'étais curé
j'ai conservé ce goût du noir ce goût de
la soutane ancien septième voilà
dissimule les formes avec c'est moi
aussi c'est au départ c'était pour être
sûr qu'on me reconnaisse puis maintenant
c'est pour dissimuler mes formes bien
alors qu'il fuyait pas si vous voulez
réussir qu'on leur connaît
on parlait de mode clip qui s'appelle
1999 le ciel le feu du ciel chez michel
lafon
mais avant j'aimerais qu'on parle de
vous parce qu'on vend souvent dans des
émissions de télévision et je suis sûr
que les jeunes générations ne savent pas
ce que vous avez fait avance de lui
apporter à la mode et on va quand même
en parler un petit peu
serge si vous pouviez basculer la
lumière l'attaquant cosy c'est bien
alors vous êtes né en 1934 à san
sebastien votre père était militaire il
a été fusillé par la fait partie des dix
sept militaires fuzier pas franco à la
prison de san antonio
oui pays basque ou là à ce moment là
vous êtes venu en france à l'âge de 5
ans avec une concentration a à revendre
argelès et ensuite caché par tanguy
prigent ministre socialiste en bretagne
au péril de sa vie puisque ma mère était
recherché par la gestapo
oui alors ce que je comprends pas très
bien c'est que votre père a été fusillé
par franck cours et vous avez pourtant
accepté d'être décoré cet officier de
l'ordre d'isabelle la catholique c'est
par le roi d'espagne est pas la même
chose d'affreux impôts j'ai toujours
refusé d'aller en espagne invité par le
général franco ou des bonnes raisons
parce que ma mère était encore vivante
et je ne pouvais pas aller dans le
haut-pays de l'assassin de mon père mais
le roi d'espagne pour considérer que
maintenant tout va carlos est un
fabuleux extraordinaire de jeu pour lui
un énorme respect on est d'accord tu as
qu on est d'accord
dix mois dites moi pardon donc votre
vous à paris à 20 ans vous faites les
uns pour faire l'architecturé arm gmail
architecture payer vos études vous
commencez par la revente des boutons à
balancier haga puis des accessoires des
accessoires à tous les couturiers ce qu
apparaît le liban et agri modifié tas de
gens qui ont disparu aujourd'hui alors
un jour vous faites un défilé de mode
c'est pour ça que je voulais en parler
parce que je ne sais pas si les jeunes
générations sont au courant qu'ils
s'appellent deux robes 1 et alors là
pour la première fois parce qu'il faut
bien dire c'est vous qui l'avez fait
pour la première fois pour la première
fois on voit des robes en plastique
enfin matières plastiques en en papier
en cuir c'est une révolution parce
qu'elle est pas que ça il ya eu aussi
vous avez fait défiler les premières
finnois annoncé ma venue
de l'est quand j'ai fait défiler ses la
couture vous attendiez à cause de ça on
les américaines d'ailleurs la fille de
vogue et de la part de gens m'ont craché
au visage
ouais c'était avant dans time modique
pourquoi vous prenez ses fils à ma vie
parce qu'elles sont les plus belles du
monde et chartes qui montera chocolat au
milieu des années 60 c'était en 64 oui
c'est à 64 gb je voulais je voulais
représenter la planète entière et les
femmes n'en a été des plus belles de
l'époque mais vous l'avez toujours
l'état vend beaucoup de gens donc avait
lisette malidor qu'on a connu et le mali
madly acquis après a été avec jacques
brel
cathy rosiers cathy rosiers moyen des
tomes
il a fallu attendre saint-laurent bien
des années plus tard douze ans après
voilà pourquoi on retrouve une noire
dans l'est dans les défilés alors vous
transforme et ça les fait défiler des
défis noir est aussi avant faut savoir
que dans les défilés de mode yves et des
aboyeurs qui a annoncé les cas lancer le
modèle vous été le premier à mettre de
la musique dans les défier j'aimais
beaucoup la musique des beatles musique
des stones c'était vraiment une époque
formidable années 60 où il y avait
vraiment la musique faisait partie du
quotidien
vous avez déjà beaucoup de fans et déjà
à l'époque vous vous aviez même genre
d'idée que maintenant parce qu'on 71
vous disiez avec l'ère du verseau les
gens vont se dénuder 161 et depuis
effectivement là la mode val de plus en
plus vers le nu même non non non ce nous
sommes entrés dans l'ère du verseau 94
nous allons revenir maintenant pour une
mode différent où il n'y aura pas cette
espèce de de nudité trop flagrantes
parce qu'elle ne trouve que dans le jeu
de l'amour dans le jeu de l'érotisme
il vaut mieux suggérer que montrer bien
sûr elle dit à s'exporter inscrit des
gens plus jolie quand on quand on voit
quelqu'un
habillé qu'on puisse suggérer une
certaine essentielle d'imaginaire et peu
importe avec de l'ère du verseau et
indirects moi j'aime bien leur nouvelle
ère du verseau est là pour 2600 ans
ouais donc il vaut mieux ça que vous
publiez un livre un jour chez laffont 90
trajectoire j'avais 60 ans 60 soutenu
cette recherche ésotérique que j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 6 ans 17 ans pardon
à 7 ans j'ai commencé à sortir de mon
corps à faire des voyages astraux mais
c'est une chose que ma grand mère était
une magicienne le disions en parler me
disait tu te tais toi n'en parle pas
regardez la réaction de ta mère c'est
vrai père me disait que j'étais je
devenais fou et donc j'ai 4 continue à
travailler en temps mais thézan et quand
je suis arrivé à 60 ans je me suis dit
bon bah ce tome mais maintenant que la
fin de ma vie je vais porter témoignage
voilà alors dans ce livre dont qui s'est
vendu à un million d'exemplaires
trajectoire vous parlez d'un coup des
langues
louis de l'ère du verseau la
réincarnation de vos vies antérieures
celles activement la découverte que vous
aviez été grand prêtre à athènes lors de
l'assassinât toutankhamon oui j'étais le
prêtre qui a enseigné la cosmogonie
égyptienne à aménophis iv qui est devenu
ensuite akhenaton est un jeune prince
égyptien qui s'appelait aussi c est qu
un jour akhenaton allait appeler sauvé
des eaux
mosher comment vous savez ça parce que
je sais pas ce que donne mes voyages
astraux la roma tout appris la prochaine
fois ramené un truc cci matériel s'est
déchaussé des flashs des des
informations qui sont virtuelles qu'on
ne peut pas ramener sur sa géniale
on a fait un récit laurent a changé dit
il y a de cela 40 50 puisque dans mon
atelier d'architecturé pour gus opéré il
y avait les plus grands égyptologue
était là comme traitement robichon qui
aujourd'hui 90 ans et qui fait autorité
là-bas à louxor quand j'ai dit que
j'étais le rappelle le prêtre qui avait
assassiné toutankhamon il m'a dit mais
il faut temps comme on n'a jamais être
assassiné il est mort de sa belle mort
j'ai dit non il a été assassiné et c'est
à 10 ans que les égyptologues américains
ont découvert qu'ils avaient été
assassinés que je lui avais défoncé le
crâne
vous oui bien sûr pourquoi vous aimez il
ya trop de gardes nationaux continuent
dans celui dans ce livre donc dans celui
trajectoire vous disiez aussi xavier
était une prostituée une jeune
prostituée ou est réduite en objet a
ainsi enlevé par les dragons du roi a
mené à celui de plaisir qui s'appelait
le parc aux cerfs dans les champs
elysées et j'ai servi de chair fraîche
au rouet du roi et à la lui 15
balladur sympa comme ça bon alors en
fait vous êtes vous êtes ballerines youn
en tout cas parce que je trouve que vu
le prix que ça coûte de faire des
voyages astraux avec des vraies fusées
tout ça mais ça lui coûte pas un rond
après tout ils emmerdent personnes on va
laisser faire il n'y a pas de raisons
secrètes en fait mouche à nous coûte
rien ah non non jusque là en fait vous
êtes basque et vous descendez des
atlantes nous expliquer les laissant des
autres vous expliquer l'unicité du
peuple base par le fait qu'ils
descendent des attentes vers l'allemagne
oui comme la nation qui dirait un
continent qui était au mieux nous serons
attentifs quoi de dire que vous êtes une
vieille âme réincarné dans des
poulaillers de sur cette planète mais
souvenez remonte plus loin il ya 78
mille ans oui si vous êtes venus ici sur
terre il ya 78 ans en 2000 en venant de
la conservation de l'est pas ça va la
mairie de secrets en venant d'hawaï
maintenant de sept soleils bleus en fin
de cette étoile bleue qui s'appelle
altaïr nous étions venus commencer une
civilisation ordonné dans ce monde plane
terrestre ou les cromagnons avait réussi
à détruire de l'aîné en der tallien qui
étaient des animaux ou des humanoïdes un
peu lent frustrés et nous sommes venus
ici pour leur apporter une une
civilisation et un ordre
si on me demande de faire un régime et
je peux pas là
je ne sais il paraît que vous ramenez un
truc plus tard j'ai déconné en disant
que pourquoi vous nous ramenez pas
quelque chose mais il paraît que dans
chaque vie il reste une forme d'oreille
enfin voilà il ya des souvenirs theresa
may vous vous même vous les avez parfois
vous aller dans un pays tiers
total veut dire que demain vous allez
dans un pays dans un lieu est
brusquement celui vous le reconnaissez
vous dire que je suis bien celui
derrière ça va se passer comme ça comme
ça où vous rencontrez un être et c'est
êtes vous êtes un différend vous n'avez
pas connu ou à naître
bruce quand vous êtes attirés vers cet
homme vers cette femme vers ce vieillard
et d'une façon irrésistible complètement
illogique parce que il a été très proche
de vous dans une vie passée à vous
expliquer le déjà vu ce qu'on appelle le
tg je vis antérieures mais bien sûr
est-ce que je t'explique les choses
aussi un bon vécu chez la jetta je n'ai
pas vu que j'étais bon nyon qui est
bouddhiste au viiie siècle au japon nara
lé sens pas que la musique c'est le
contraste était quoi c'est un officier
austro-hongrois ans s'écoulent en 1815
par l'ag pas que moi c'est non aimez
vous avez lutté contre napoléon 1er mais
c'est limité sur pattes heures alors
dites moi y'a un truc quand même pas eut
demandé ce que j'étais moi je veux pas
savoir c'est un choix
vous l'avez cherché lent alors là pas qu
il ya un truc quand même c'est bien plus
tard quand vous êtes parti d'alpha yaya
dans le 78 mille ans vous étiez en train
de faire l'amour faisais pas l'amour sur
altaïr mais vous étiez marée noire on
est des épisodes des humanoïdes j'étais
un homme de chair et en os vous faisiez
quand même l'amour quand vous êtes père
bien sûr nous étions des gens sérieux
quand vous a envoyé sur la sphère du
tremplin entre un gouvernement
et c'est pour ça que vous avez déclaré
la baise m'a toujours dégoûté c'est à
dire parce que c'est parce que vous avez
vu ce qu ils tuent s'est interrompue sur
al nahyan 78 ans
vous tenez vous ces informations cela a
été un grand buteur quand j'étais jeune
alors donnez vous avez été vous dit que
vous avez été plus haut jusqu'à l'âge de
30 ans je sais par bateau oui mais moi
je lis tous les jours dans la presse des
trucs hallucinants par exemple que j'ai
annoncé la fin du monde
on est d'accord c'est énorme ou alors
que j'ai payé des billets de 2 trains
tous les ouvrières pour qu'elles partent
en juin oui bonjour je fais ma
collection oui je l'avais eu lieu le 11
août la maison paco rabanne et attendez
si bien compris c'est un trou dans la
terre et non au cij après je dis comment
comment la première fois que j'ai baisé
le cueille le premier set et j'avais 9
ans à 12 ans en bretagne profonde a
morlaix à morlaix j'avais une envie
déjà rien faire lamorlaye j'en à 12 ans
à l'époque il m'avait passé télémistes
télévision permissif tous ses écrits etc
eh bien j'ai fait un trou dans la terre
et j'ai joui j'ai baisé le sol j'ai joué
et au moment où je vous en supplie les
vieilles tounes et des finances
ça va être difficile de se préparer
sérieusement ici si on le regarde et me
réjouis il ya eu un tremblement de terre
ça des religions frémissement et il ya
le désir d'y aller quand il n'y a eu un
flash blanc de lumière et les parfums de
bruit hier d'âge ont bon goût et elle
continue à livrer et je raconte
simplement les choses telles qu'elles
sont passées puisque nous somme une épée
vous croire du total permissivité on
peut tout dire bien entendu sauf que
donc vous vous dites aujourd'hui moi je
m'en fou j'étais putallaz aujourd'hui
officiellement ce soit et quoi gagner
une [ __ ]
c'est là le ballon vous n'avez pas été
plus haut jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans occupe
à présent déjà unique
alors votre vie votre vie actuelle paco
votre vie actuelle est la dernière avant
votre retour sur altaïr ça c'est vrai
nom d'incarnation terrestre et la
dernière puisque j'ai accompli tous tous
les cycles bon si vous êtes vous le
savez pas mais les 6 6 1 un temps deux
temps la moitié d'un temps pendant
l'antéchrist aussi viendra il règnera un
temps de temps la moitié des teintes en
un temps et en un mois pour lui donc ça
fera quarante sept mois sam et moi
c'était à tant de temps la moitié d'un
temps c'est-à-dire 78 milan puisque le
soleil mais soit 25 25 mille années à
faire le tour des 12 signes sont
logiques
mais il c'est une question de
connaissance le savoir vous êtes à
savoir perdu à savoir une juste dont je
suis parti à lacq est à la quête de ce
savoir quand j'avais 7 ans très bien
alors justement justement pas que votre
grand mère était médium comme faut le
dire nous a dit ce sens éthique c'est le
nom
non on va l'arrêter médium malgré son de
sa dialectique marxiste était marxiste
ma mère elle était médium médias les
médias mais ma grand mère je suis dit
qu'une grande magicienne ouais elle m'a
pris dès le secret de l'eau le secret du
100 m après nature qu'elle nous a dit
c'est toi qui a reçu le ton de la
famille sanchez n'y a rien donc qui se
transmet du gérant sûr que votre mère
elle voulait pas elle voulait pas
l'assumer parce qu'effectivement elle
était marxiste que vous venez de le dire
mais votre mère faisait quand même
voulez vous appelez rue ben ouais et dit
tout ce que ces ruelles rubin l'archange
en revanche très important la porte du
verso de portes du verset jérusalem mais
oui donc c'est passé dessine tous
amateurs alors le livre s'appelle 1999
le feu du ciel donc je le montre voilà
la caméra comme on fait à la télévision
c'est mon huitième boucle c'est votre
huitième bouquin c'est chez michel lafon
et ce sera que là parce que les gens
n'ont retenu avant j'ai déjà mais le
plus que jamais et j'ai pendant deux ans
j'ai voulu faire ce bouquin parce que
c'est une vision racontez nous la
présentons comme jeudi 17 ans quand
j'avais 17 ans je suis venu à paris pour
moi est ce que rob aux arrêts à
l'atelier de vue d'auguste perret pour l
architecture et quand je me promenais
dans les rues de paris
j'étais obligé de me boucher les
oreilles car j'entendais les hurlements
des gentils ce qui brûle est vive dans
les rues et je voyais les gens puisque
nous étions quai malaquais oppose à se
jeter dans la seine continue à brûler
dans l'eau et ce truc me perturbait
j'étais obligé de me boucher les
oreilles et cette vision m'a poursuivi
très longtemps et quand j'ai commencé à
étudier toutes les prophéties qui depuis
le quatrième siècle que ce soit
sainte-odile tout tout tout y en a des
milliers des centaines
tout parle de cette évangéline près de
paris un jour brûlures à il ya deux ans
j'ai réalisé que ça allait être
maintenant et il ya deux ans comme je le
disais nostradamus depuis 45 ans
possiblement le famous est entièrement
ouvert une façon très simple
or il y a deux personnes qui donnent le
parce qu'on sait que paris un jour
périra dans les flammes c'est dans
toutes les prophéties on ne sait pas
quand
car cet amateur de ne pas savoir or il
ya deux personnes qui donne des tapes
c'est nostradamus dans le fameux 4 ans
en 1999
voilà on y va d'ailleurs c'est ma
dixième century ne sera dalhousie du
ciel viendra des filières des frayeurs
en 1999 c'est donc la seule date que
donne nostradamus et toutes ces
prophéties et il ya une voyante de la
fraude et marie-julie jannier
extraordinaire l'équipement en 1946 qui
dit avant la série la fin du siècle
paris brûlera et ça sera pendant d'une
journée obscur oued à dire lesquels il
éclaire soleil alors moi j'ai cherché je
me suis dit qu'est-ce qui ça peut être
la fille serait pas là à penser aux
autres
non mais moi je croyais au début du
week-end à un astéroïde géant
ouais allait venir frapper paris ouais
et que la ville était détruite et dans
un il ya deux ans dans une conférence
jeunes et en province a été chercheur du
cnrs m'a dit monsieur rabat nous avons
répertorié tous les objets célestes
rien ne viendra frapper la terre en 99
mais me dit il
c'était il ya deux ans j'étais pas au
courant je me dis la station mir et en
très mauvais état actuellement les étés
ya deux ans elle descend de plus en plus
flux son orbite basse et nous pensons
qu'elles veulent s'abîmera sur la terre
en 99
je dis ça ou ça ne me dit dans l'océan
pacifique au dessus les médias disent
parle toujours de vendre sa météo ayant
pas cité oui et moi je l'aimé hier et ce
qu'il y ait une orbite qui passe au
dessus de paris me dit oui une orbite de
qui passe au dessus paris et il me dit
c'est lui qui me dit et nous savons
qu'il ya du plutonium
à l'intérieur les oxydes de plus tard
magella émond et là j'ai eu un flash et
vu cette bombe
voilà vous avez vu cette mesure mais
j'ai tout les féminines d'ailleurs
adamus se sont ouverts vous dites que
donc ce que vous dites c'est qu'il y
aura suite à l'équipe ce nom mais vous
allez poser une question mais je viens
que ce soit clair pour tout le monde
c'est pas évident au sol et deux
éclipses voilà il ya une éclipse
attendez attendez attendez à une et 28
juillet à l'avancé la théorie d'une
éclipse le 28 juillet juillet et qui
faisait une première jamais
vous dites que les interférences
magnétiques créé par ces éclipses vont
faire tomber le 11 août 1999 à 11 heures
22 heures 22 22 abbaye de ses nièces
voilà cimiez il y à une fraise énorme
qui t'a du xviie siècle et lis tu
connaîtras leur de ta mort mais pas le
jour et on voit l'église de soleil
dessiner une horloge qui est arrêté à en
sortir de 22 alors ce que vous dites
c'est que en fait la station mir
aujourd'hui que si une station
soviétique enfin russe désormais c'est
une bombe atomique sur orbite
kiki à peu près la puissance de 1000
hiroshima c'est ça mais écoutez mire été
conçu par monsieur presov qui n'était
pas un tendre n'ya rigolo et quand il a
lancé nous mais comme mir
ces cours leur chef des enseignants mais
c'était l'objet de 11,9
regan à la lancer sa fameuse guerre des
étoiles a dit si les russes de lance d
engin contenant des bombes atomiques
nous nous allons lancer des engins tueur
17 et u alors c'est pas moi qui le dit
ce qu'avance une question ils vont
relier poser une question mais je suis
perdu une ânesse qui suivait je n'avance
j'attends bien j'entends bien non mais
je suis perdue parce que ça peut avoir
des conseils des conséquences incroyable
ce que vous nous raconter non ici mais
aussi à des absences il ya des gens qui
peut vous croire et je me dis c'est un
allumé les voyants sont faits pour être
allumées ya des gens qui veut aborder
les actions violentes
justement j'ai une demande pardon je je
je m'y attendais je m'étonne et je
pensais vous dire une chose quand j'ai
voulu m'arrêter de parler à 94,1 j'ai
été voir une jeune femme seema tease une
nonne et la vierge nous est apparue la
vierge lui a dit dit à mon fils
bien-aimé paco rabanne que surtout ils
n'arrêtent pas de parler
nous voulons qu'il continue de parler
qui ne craignent rien de là où nous le
protégerons or moi quand j'ai créé ce
bouquin je me dis ah c'est suffisamment
de cons dans paris il ya suffisamment de
dingue
je veux recevoir des lettres de dengue
et je vais recevoir des crachats des
agents
à ma grande surprise je reçois des
lettres actuellement jeunes et tout ça
sur mon gros fabuleuse l'aide
merci de voirie etc pas comme un truc
quand vous avez écrit ça c'est aller
voir votre éditeur inquiets michel lafon
et qui vous a dit tu peux pas écrire ça
et oui il m'a dit que je faisais déjà le
caniche à la fois il m'a publié moi
aussi d'ailleurs tu me dois de l'argent
michel et vous vous dites à ce moment là
j'ai deux solutions soit je me tais et
je perds le sommeil et je deviens fou
face à retrouver samy soit je parle et
je risque de passer pour un fou cela dit
donc j'ai préféré être ridicule disons à
bien dormir maintenant qu'ils ont fait
c'est quand même un peu les autres de
dormir mais les sigmen sûrement pas si
le petit site s'il est pas la leur aux
autres fai ne se passera emma la
destruction de parité qui est important
c'est que les gens au monsieur rabat
c'est pas possible monsieur vient
d'acheter un studio mais c'est pas si tu
as mais bon qu'est ce que je fais moi la
suite
moi j'ai fait une petite annonce
immobilière vue de chute de satellites
y'a un truc qui me le dit tout à l'heure
c'est que les prophéties était fait
pourquoi il contrarie alors est-ce que
l'on peut renvoyer vous que j'écris ce
bout alors est-ce qu'on peut sauver je
parle plus et ce bouquin pour que cela
n'arrive pas jusqu'où nous qu'est-ce que
passer dans un journal du matin le
figaro pour ne pas le nommer il y à un
mois et demi
c'est un article comme ça les russes
demandent aux américains qu'on leur
prête
là c'est la navette atlantis pour aller
chercher quelque chose de très important
dans la station mir
les américains répondent attendait
qu'est ce que c'est que vous les mettez
les russes ne répondent pas les
arméniens ont répondu c'est écrit noir
sur blanc
nous ne pouvons pas vous prêtez la
navette atlantis lancer la navette
atlantis coûte 5 milliards de dollars et
que les gouvernements du monde dont 1,5
milliard de dollars aux russes tout ça
comme ça ils démontrent la religion prix
astrid une question
20 milliards aux russes pour demander
l'appartement vers ce que tu dénonces et
deux éclipses
les études prouvent qu'il y en a qu'une
donc non je parle à ceux qui savent bien
compris votre cas on va y revenir après
terminé différentes une lune de 28
juillet et ça c'est scientifique tout à
l'heure le mon contradicteur qui va
venir
voilà on a pensé rigole vous vous dire
aussi parce que moi les scientifiques
qui me disent que le nuage de tchernobyl
s'était arrêté aux frontières françaises
parce qu'il n'avait pas de visa et ben
moi je rigole quand l'état de départ
bien maintenant on arrive à conclure
pour cette course il m'a super g
dernière j'ai un ami puisque je connais
je vais souvent en argentine vient de
m'appeler de woodside dans le nord de la
vénère jeudi pour les suspects soient là
bon en même temps dans un soyouz est
tombé en argentine au nord d'un gentil
ni contenait du plutonium mais c'était
simplement moteur plutonium et donc vous
voyez c'est plus sympa alors on te les
gardes avant
après d'albas à paris dont c'est la
chanson pour que vieillir et corrigé par
frank gehry s'accorder attendez attendez
qu'on m'a dit on à son bord on va en
rester là on va en rester là pour le
moment la seule chose jean pagé
paraissait alors et on va en rester là
on amène à lever de l'argent et astrid
je suis travailler le 11 août et vous
avez raison le carrière donc un explosé
alors vous avez dit paco rabanne si je
me trompe je ne parlerai plus jamais de
profession vous le dit à la télévision
ça c'est par une religion vous
rediffusera la bande à chaque interview
pendant 78 millions bien sûr si on
demande pas la bombe c'est tout ça que
ça te regarde et bien sûr au vu et au su
de tout le bon gars s'il n'arrive pas je
ferme ma gueule définitive accord
puisque c'est pour le 11 août
et puisque tout va être détruit à paris
le 11 août est ce qu'on peut dire assez
de lancer un appel à tous les parisiens
attendent et le 12 août pour acheter
quoi que ce soit chez paco rabanne
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non je dis simplement j'ai des amis qui
veulent la chaîne appartement je le dis
at en septembre alors